[Music]
the modern fallout games as we know them
today could have been very very
different fallout new vegas developer
obsidian has revealed to cancel fallout
three projects i'm lucy and welcome to
your sliding doors gamespot news updates
fergus aircard CEO of fallout new vegas
developer obsidian entertainment told
IGN that the company worked on multiple
fallout three projects in its previous
guys as Black Isle Studios her car true
calls one project that went on to become
Icewind Dale he said now 3d was the cool
stuff so we were going to move from
being a 2d engine and be a 3d engine and
so we actually started working with this
3d technology called ndl what happened
was we were moving forward but we were
really learning and it was where
interplay the studios and fall outs then
publisher started to run into financial
trouble and that was where Icewind Dale
came from the fallout 3 team became the
icewind dale team her card says the
company wanted to make icewind dale as a
dungeon crawling counterpoint to
Baldur's Gate small story driven
elements this wasn't the only fallout 3
project however the CEO said another
version code named van buren was the
second fallout 3 after the first one
became icewind dale van buren has been
more widely reported and you can see
footage of it on youtube eventually
blackout studios which develop both the
original Fallout and fallout 2 was shut
down by interplay and Bethesda took over
the Fallout franchise many of Black Isle
staff went on to work for obsidian which
has since developed Fallout New Vegas so
would you want to play one of these
cancelled for our games are you happy
with the direction that the franchise
went be sure to let us know in the
comments below for more on Fallout make
sure to LIKE and subscribe to gamespot
you
[Music]